wir schauen auf diese geschichte völlig
betrunken sollen die mitglieder des
kegelclubs stammtische aus münster
zigarettenkippen von ihrem hotel balkon
auf malle geschnippt und so ein feuer
ausgelöst haben bei denen dann eine bar
abbrannte aber stimmt das alles
überhaupt das ist eine der wichtigsten
fragen die wir uns und all unsere
reporter seit tagen stellen die 13
kegelfreunde waren nach mallorca
geflogen um mal richtig die sau
rauszulassen tja und jetzt sitzen sie im
knast ihr anwalt geht nun in die
offensive und sagt dass die jungs zur
tatzeit gar nicht am tatort waren und
sie allein aus rein logistischer sicht
das schiff dach der bar mit ihren
zigaretten gar nicht hätten treffen
können unseren bild reportern liegen
jetzt sogar die chat verläufe vor die
ein ganz neues bild zeichnen
13 kegelbrüder aus münster auf mallorca
in knallhart knast eine mafia knast und
immer wieder die frage sind sie wirklich
schuldig ihr anwalt geht jetzt in die
offensive sagt stadt täter waren die
deutschen helfer und retter das
dokumentieren text und sprachnachrichten
die die kegler während des feuers an
angehörige geschickt haben bild kennt
den chep verlauf der ein ganz neues bild
der schreckensmoment bezeichnet als
dieses gruppenfoto entsteht ist die
meile welt noch in ordnung ist soll das
vorerst letzte gruppenbild der meile 13
sein nach dem strand soll es kurz ins
hotel gehen bevor der abend richtig
startet einer der 13 schreibt nach hause
die anderen menschen auch duschen ihr
schätzchen auf dem balkon und sprachen
zum zeitpunkt des brandausbruchs sind
die männer gerade erst auf mallorca
angekommen sie wollen zum bierkönig sich
vorher aber noch frisch machen dann
diese whatsapp an die familie in
deutschland es riecht plötzlich
verbrannt hier als die jungs das feuer
bemerkten sollen sie nicht abgewartet
haben ist die feuerwehr kommt sondern
selbst aktiv geworden sein nach
bild-informationen schreiben sie im chat
es hat gedauert bis die feuerwehr kam
die haben sofort nachbarn gewarnt und
auch zimmertüren eingetreten und so
mindestens 30 leuten das leben gerettet
die meile 13 anstatt sünder lebensretter
in den sprachnachrichten ist einer der
jungs mit klar nicht verwaschener stimme
zu hören keinesfalls sternhagelvoll die
spanische feuerwehr ist wirklich spät
eingetroffen und es wurde auch nicht
professionell gearbeitet nicht wie wir
das in deutschland machen nach dieser
nachricht gründen die angehörigen sofort
eine ortsgruppe um sich zu vernetzen
doch die kommunikation zu ihren kindern
reist plötzlich ab später wird klar die
polizei hat die handys beschlagnahmt
die nachrichten reißen ab die eltern
hören nach der feuermeldung nichts mehr
von ihren kindern als sie 13 auf der
wache sitzen werden ihre handys
eingesammelt nun wird in el arenal über
einen möglichen versicherungsbetrug
gesprochen die ihm die ermittler
nachgehen sollten auffällig sei dass
sowohl dort als auch das darunter
liegende bordell genau am tag des
brandes wieder eröffnen wollten nach
langer corona durststrecke
unschuldig im knast
versicherungsbetrug auf kosten deutscher
urlauber waren die deutschen stadt täter
helfer und retter fragen die die
spanische justiz jetzt klären muss die
stammtischfreunde sitzen noch immer in
alle klassen
tja da waren wir ein wenig versuchen
licht ins dunkle zu bringen schalten wir
direkt zu ari suhl lies dorf nach
mallorca die mit den kollegen vor ort
seit tagen schon an diesem fall
recherchiert aristo stehst vor dem hotel
von dem aus die kegelbrüder diese kippen
angeblich auf diese bar geschnitzt haben
sollen und jetzt kommt heraus sehr viele
dieser kegelbrüder haben gar nicht zur
straße hin gewohnt sondern hatten
vielleicht zimmer zum hinterhof wie ist
die lage vor ort
genau wir stehen direkt davor und wir
können uns einmal die balkone angucken
und war die außen balkone da sollten sie
eigentlich vorerst gestanden haben um
dort ihr runter auf die gefahr auf das
schiff retten ich geworben aber laut
unseren leuchten in kommandeuren waren
sie halt weil man von rechts wie weit
vorne anfängt zu den
nicht ganz auf den außen balkon recht
sondern auf dem immer bei knapp etage
auf dem
auf dem dritten balkon und dort über von
da aus direkten runter auf dieses dach
gastgewerbe eher unwahrscheinlich
aber so was hast du denn er vor ort von
der spanischen justiz
bewegt sich die staatsanwaltschaft
mittlerweile im stück weit
von der justiz jürgen wie im moment
immer nur dasselbe und zwar dass die
jungs sich das wissen wir schon ohne
kaution im gefängnis befinden und die
polizei erst noch ermittelt und es
könnte halb drei wochen dauern aber auch
bis zu ein jahr bis dann jetzt endlich
schluss als ich feststellte was
überhaupt passiert ist das heißt wenn es
ganz ganz böse läuft dann könnten die 13
jungs tatsächlich ein jahr dort im knast
verharren hast du informationen darüber
wie es ihm geht
wir haben natürlich die wenig kontakt
zur außenwelt telefonieren dürfen
knapp eine minute nur am anfang ja und
wie ich kann sich eigentlich ein
gefängnis wo auch schon ganz andere
leute sagen ach es ist ja auch was still
of money
wegen geldwäsche in dem gefängnis und
ja wir warten halt die ganze zeit auch
staatsanwaltschaft und vollen halt
wissen was passiert wird mit den
deutschen jungs
am besten dank für diese informationen
live vor ort auf new york